amid the economic malaise in afghanistan
there's one market raking in cash and
that's the opium trade the un has
reported a record opium harvest in the
country for the fifth year running
fueling trade worth up to 2.7 billion
dollars annually now over a hundred
thousand afghans are involved in growing
and selling opium with local power
brokers and drug traffickers taking a
big chunk of the profits now for many
farmers growing opium is the only way to
make ends meet dw correspondent nick
connolly met some of them
these are definitely not scenes
afghanistan's new taliban rulers want
the outside world to see
opium being smoked and sold in broad
daylight this bridge has long been home
to kabul's best known community of drug
users but now its members are starting
to disappear rounded up nightly by
taliban patrols and taken to forcible
treatment centers
they come and beat us up if they catch
you you're sure to get a beating
they tell us to stop using drugs and
change our ways
and they go after the dealership
after years of earning protection money
from the illegal drug trade while
fighting their insurgency against
afghanistan's western back government
the taliban now say they want to put an
end to the cultivation and use of what
is by most estimates the country's most
valuable export this at a time of
extreme stress for the country's farmers
drought plummeting consumer demand and
border closures have seen their incomes
dwindle
the one crop still performing for these
farmers is the opium poppy here in
kandahar province it sold openly
alongside the farmers of the produce
[Music]
the only thing the taliban announcement
changed these farmers tell us was to
drive opium prices up at a time when
prices for other crops are collapsing
[Music]
i just harvested onions and couldn't
even sell them for 20 cents a sack
we know this is an illegal crop and it's
not right
these are illegal drugs and we know that
but what else can we do
with afghanistan's land borders largely
shut for legal exports entire harvests
of pomegranates and other crops have
rotted or been sold for a pittance while
smuggling roots for opium and cannabis
have stayed open
this farmer lost his leg to a soviet
landmine as a child
more recently his village saw repeated
american bombing rates targeting taliban
insurgents they in turn brought their
own improvised minds leaving some fields
too dangerous to cultivate his fields
they tell us are too dry for most crops
this year even for opium puppies so he's
planted cannabis instead
apart from the leaves which we sell we
also get the seeds to feed our chickens
and the stems to use for straw it gives
us three harvests in one and doesn't go
bad in storage like onions or corn
margins here are tight even at the best
of times right now he's struggling to
find the 20 euros per month he needs to
send one of his sons to school
money he has no chance of making with
legal crops
if the international community was
helping us we wouldn't be growing
cannabis or opium poppies of course we'd
rather grow legal crops we do the labor
and get the blame but the big profits
end up with the foreign smugglers
but for now there's little prospect of
international aid returning in anything
like the volume seen under the previous
government without it afghanistan's
economy looks set to suffer for the
foreseeable future opening the way for
more poppies and more cannabis across
these fields and more narcotics on the
streets of afghanistan's neighbours
i'm joined now by angela may she is from
the united nations office on drugs and
crime
based in vienna
uh angela thank you for joining us
afghanistan faces two major problems
here drug use and drug production how
big a problem is this for the afghan
society
well if we look at the opiate use so it
means the use of arrow in an opium this
is estimated to be among the highest in
the world
and due to this of course the supply
that they have but also due to the
continued stress and conflict situation
that the population has been facing for
the last
uh decades that has created a lot of
also mental health uh problems like
post-traumatic stress disorders and
these are all factors that we all know
are
related to drug use and particularly
drug use dependence and in a country
where not only the drug use
um is very high
the treatment of provision and supply is
also very low uh in our last uh survey
uh we saw that only 10
of the people who are dependent on drugs
can have access to the treatment
and so these are also
the problem not only on the use but also
the lack of basic
services and treatment for drug use
in terms of production also is uh
um afghanistan produce 85 percent of all
the supply of opiates
around the world
and supply 80 percent of the
people who use opiates around the world
and so clearly has the biggest again
also problem of production but why is
this a problem for people and angela
just going to come in there just to ask
you what's the undoing to help people in
afghanistan
both the the producers like we saw in
our report there and the consumers
well it is addressing both issues that
we were discussing the production and
the in the use so we have been helping
farmers to find alternatives and
alternatives that can help really if you
want a healthy economy to grow because
the drug
economy distorts the resource allocation
and so you have that only few can
benefit a lot but the rest of the
population actually gets poorer so in uh
so we have been helping communities to
find these alternatives and from the use
side is also helping communities to see
how to treat drug use disorder with
science-based
treatment services okay and very quickly
um how can the world help because this
is not just a problem for afghanistan
yeah there is no country in the world
that alone can solve the problem of
drugs and afghanistan of course
also and so the international community
is committed and we are meeting here
today also in vienna to discuss
uh with countries in the region and
beyond on how to enhance and find the
unity of the international community to
support
afghanistan and the region to
to reduce the trafficking but also to
see how uh you know we need to address
both product production and demand
together okay and the big demand is also
outside afghanistan all right um angela
may of the un office of on drugs and
crime thank you we'll have to leave it
there for now